each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay well thank you very much for being
in this session this is really exciting
to me I tell you why it's so exciting to
me so I don't know how many of you well
has anybody read December the mark
Morgan Stanley report on no well let me
tell you something about so let's do it
has that doesn't count so yeah that's
correct that's correct actually what is
funny about that is that the preview to
the report is like 200 slides or
something and then there's a report of
course with success nevertheless let me
know tell you something about that
report so they sort of thing looked at
the the you know computer industry the
IT and they looked over many many years
so from the 1960s to 2010 and you know
it sort of divided these these this
period into these five cycles of
innovations or five cycles as they call
him I don't remember the exact terms and
things they used but so they think of
like what happens in 1960s you had all
the mainframes you know the big large
computers and those were sold in
quantities of 10,000 maybe you know
20,000 hundred that 9000 like that so
then came the mini computers right they
were sold they they sold like you know a
few million you know maybe 10 million
million tactic then came the pcs that
was hundreds of millions right then
after pcs came the mobile averted call
is in a mood mobile internet and that
was you know that's sort of what you see
in search for example what you sing
everything about the web for example
that you're seeing and then the final
cycle is what they call which is the the
sort of the error of the smartphone or
or the Kindles of the world or you know
everything sort of mobile all right the
interesting thing about that is there's
nothing new here but the interesting
thing about that is that each of these
error that is a came create a great
economic value around it so if you
looked at if you look at it from a
perspective of you know how much money
exchanging hands to create that
particular sort of error you know it is
phenomenally difference and and and the
way sort of also to look at it is that
how many devices were being sold and how
much software and every device had
software in it and thats offer was being
sold on those device okay so now you're
selling you know billions of devices
correct they're all mobile they are
people are using it for different
reasons and each one of them is running
some software on it okay so things are
changing and the interesting thing is
that for every cycle as it came it
pretty much eliminated the old cycle so
if you think about you know when I
started my career after school I had an
offer from digital equipment corporation
this how many of you remember deck okay
well the old folks do but if you know if
you remember deck was like the big deal
big Hoonah right it was sort of like
when I got I got an offer Microsoft as
well and I got an offer from deck and I
thought to myself who the heck is going
to work for this piddly pce thing I'm a
man you know I want to work on
workstations and look at it today it's
gone right think about all the companies
like data general all the sort of the
other boroughs wang labs they all work
in this era so so what has happened is
that every era every cycle has sort of
created more value and people have
gravitated towards that and done more
with it and they've tried to sort of
pull all the functionality that they
were already accustomed to in to this
new cycle right so now we are in an area
where you know if it's sort of the
phones it's a handheld it's the mobile
devices the Kindles of the world or the
other nooks of the world or or the Sony
e-reader or whatever right so that's
where we are and a lot of companies
recognize that fact now so that's that's
definite rent and then of course the
other trend is of course you know try to
make this easier in the sense the cost
of ownership how do you reduce the cost
of ownership and that's where the cloud
is all right so so then one other
question if one other thing observation
that you realize if you work or as you
work on these devices is even though
Apple would have 100,000 apps or 200,000
apps but if you sort of really think
about it is a very sort of this is a
low-lying fruit these are
applications that you know people write
a little bit of it and then sort of do
it but if you don't want to do some
really fancy heavy duty perhaps that
require lots of processing require lots
of memory lots of battery it Sarah then
it's not clear that you can actually get
it done and when I look at a whole lot
of things that are going on the
microsoft research labs and all that
interesting applications that people are
building and you know how
compute-intensive they are how much how
resource intensive they are you start to
feel that I don't know how we can do it
in this phone because one thing that is
not changing its battery the battery
energy is not changing and I don't know
if you know this but there was a sort of
a article came out in the I Triple E
proceedings that battery energy doubles
about every 35 years okay and also if
you think about it as you put more and
more energy to the battery you're
actually creating a bomb so it's it's
sort of you're not going to get to the
point where you will have lots of lots
of batteries okay the other problem that
is happening is the spectrum it's we
don't have enough spectrum so we don't
have the capability of of doing
everything the way it sort of getting
used to now anyway so so you know as we
sort of think about this new word of
course you know we in research have many
many projects now that try to go after
these problems like you know we we have
a project called Maui which sort of
talks about how do you take an
application partition it and offloaded
the idea being that you want the cloud
to assist the mobile device all right
now as we as we go into this thing we
started to realize that of course you
know lots of innovation happening and
what we need to do is we need to equip
so these people who are similar students
and young kids who are working this
space to this new world that is emerging
it's not necessarily the world of
desktops and it's not necessarily the
word you know sort of that as we grew up
in and this is a new word so in the New
World you have different programming
paradigms and those include the cloud
and the mobile so that's that's what
sort of the reason to start you know as
I looked around the field and I'm very
sort of connected to the the
professional world in some sense or or
the
so the academic world in because I
participated in a lot of these
conferences and and working them I
started to realize that there were very
very few courses that were being offered
and they were very very few sort of
support structures that is available so
every time I talk to a lot of the
researchers and active missions and such
as yourself in faculty you know people
who wanted to do it they had things but
they had to sort of you know do a lot of
stuff they had to reinvent a whole lot
of things okay so we've had so then you
know that got us to thinking that
perhaps in order to move things forward
perhaps we can sort of provide a bar on
which people don't have to spend time
reinventing a lot of these stuffs and
we've had some success in the past with
this I don't know if you're familiar I
know Lily's definitely is familiar
because she was in my group at the time
we we started this thing called we did
this thing called a mesh academic
toolkit this was at the time which was
around 2002 2003 when mesh networks
became very very popular and I didn't
actually become popular but they were
you know being revisited we sort of from
a commercial sector and so a lot of the
universities who are very interested in
in teaching courses in that area but
every time you would go in there the
students would be protocol writing
things like routing protocols and if you
sort of looked at a loud number of
routing protocols they were like
hundreds of routing protocols already
out there so it was sort of but they had
to do something like that in order to
get their meshes up and things so we we
created this thing called the mesh net
one kid when we provide a lot of
software we provided a lot of support
and we provided in the kit form and we
distributed it and and I remember more
than 900 universities i think it was
1200 but well because the 900
universities took this and started to
teach a lot of courses so we had massive
about a success so we had done this in
2005 and because of the success we did
it again in 2007 and that succeeded so
now moving forward in 2010 you know
there's a general feeling now is again
that you're we are in a stage where we
understand pull out some what I guess we
understand mobile somewhat address and
how do we enable sort of the students to
be creative and start to build on let's
try to understand the dynamics of a
cloud and and the mobile and try to do
it so the Hawaii project is essentially
that it is it provides sort of a
substrate it's prob
I some basic set of services tools I
mean I think of it as as you know you're
familiar with the app store concept
think of it as a service store concept
so what we do is we actually will
provide we provide a bunch of services
you know similar to what as or provide
so if you know about ads or you know as
it provides you with weird storage and
computation but to that if you sort of
think about mobility the world of mobile
you need things like alerting services
right you have something happen and you
want an alert to happen so the phone
gets up and does something to it
similarly you need location services
right and so similarly you need other
things like you know what Brian will
talk about you know mapping services
because location and mapping is quite
fundamental together ordinarily together
so we thought we'd put this bundle of
services together and offer it to
academics along with all the supporting
documentation and help to program these
services and we will also provide you
know windows phones for example and
provide whatever it will software that
needs to get on the windows phone so
that students can now start to build
these fancy interesting services or
applications on top of this framework
and so that's that's what it is but in
the meantime what we hope to learn from
ourself it's you know it's also the fact
that you know that Microsoft is very
much a platform company and when you
look at you know how sort of we've
succeeded you look at our win32 for
example you know which was a reason for
our big success was it in some sense
commoditize the pc so people could write
lots and lots of application on this
standard API so the hope is that as more
and more students use this stuff as you
teach as these teach courses on this
stuff what will emerge from it would be
these needs that are pretty uniform
across different different applications
that those needs then we'll give us some
understanding of what that platform the
new platform should look like right so
today these things are just thrown out
there I mean you have you can program
the phone and you can provide program
the cloud but if you to assume that
these two have to work together to do
the really fancy stuff so for example
there is a class of applications that
iphone for example doesn't deliver as
much or you know g phone or whatever
deliver as much which is about
collaborative sensing in the academic
community as you know and people who
work in sensors you know that you know
urban sensing you know collaborative
computing a collaborative sensing all
that stuff is very cool and very
important right how do you make it easy
for people to sort of move forward
Givens we already understand these
things so Hawaii will provide some sort
of a setting where you would be able to
will do collaborative sensing or
collaborative computing type types of
applications very easily okay so that's
sort of generally what it is we have
been actually quite successful we have
piloted the program three universities
have have already used it for for
example the three universities being
Wisconsin do and university UCS industry
California Southern California and they
actually taught three courses this last
semester and they did some interesting
things there so one of the things they
did is they they asked though so every
one of them and I'm on record so I'm not
making this up every one of them in a
public forum told all the other
colleagues that we had a range of sort
of a Hawaii bash in mobile sisters here
in public forum said that every student
had an amazing time during this course
and they got amazing feedback in fact
one of the professor's went up and said
his review ratings academic ratings went
up because of this course because it
gave a lot it provided a lot of
empowerment to these students who were
now seeing all this stuff happening and
they were with the times in some sense
so what is what these professors that
for example is at least one of them in
Wisconsin he basically said okay so you
know he he taught the course they did
the regular thing read a lot of papers
on it talked about infrastructure doctor
but the cloud doctor about the mobile
that stuff and then they had these final
projects in the projects and they said
do the projects then you come up and you
could do the demo in class to everybody
else plus create a video that he put on
youtube so they had a lot of fun with
this so they so when when this professor
got up and talk to the audience he
basically his talk was all about this
video's he said look at the applications
they built
and there were some very very cool
applications that you know you would
have to think haha that's you know
pretty cool and so it started really
seeing that you know people are very
creative and they do things you know
they think very out-of-the-box not not
like you know some of us and and that
was very cool so so it really worked ok
so the good news then was so they were
you know there were lots of hiccups well
there was some hiccups here that we
tried to help and smooth out in the
process which we did but what happened
was that starting fall then we know we
decided to sort of expand the program
and of course add more services to it so
this summer we have got interns as well
as researchers working on building some
of the more interesting services so for
example one of the more interesting
service we are building is around video
multimedia right about taking taking you
know live video and passing it on the
website or moving it between phones and
things so instead of having you having
the student go and say ok do this it's
less research I mean it's no longer sort
of research right so why spend so much
time on reinventing those things and
there is some teaching element there but
so our hope is that we will provide that
substrate that that they can actually
build some really fantastic video based
web services or applications that are
across the thing I similarly we're
working on another service that that is
hasn't been fun which is about as I
already mentioned about collaborative
sensing or collaborating working right
so basically you can write programs and
we have this concept of virtual sensors
which we'll talk about later but not
here but generally which allows you to
then sort of think of the whole world
and everybody else who's using these
phones as a programming space for
yourself you don't think of individual
phones so so you know the hope is that
we will keep rolling out the service in
addition to the ones we have and yes
they will have some bugs in it and we
will learn in the process and perhaps
you'll even identify and we are
identified some really hard research
problems that we're going to work with
with the with the professors that helped
identified it if they want to work with
it themselves that's great too but we
keep moving along and and get to the
point where these things are much much
you know very interesting so in fall we
have already signed up we're going to
take this program make it international
so we've already signed up UCL Chi
he's going to be co-teaching that with
Brad I saw him here as well so you need
to call in London they're going to do it
we also signed up somebody from czech
republic with with the singapore
management institute universities you
know they want to teach a course as well
in the u.s. University of Michigan
carnegie mellon university of arkansas i
think and a bunch of others have have
sort of signed up in the sense and
signing up means essentially that you
know we are we sort of we're going to
provide them all the course material in
over a period of time hopefully develop
this into a really solid course with a
lots of sort of be aware where people
are the professor's exchange ideas and
students exchange ideas and one more
thought before i leave and give it a
brined which is that in in in the world
that I live in today it is no longer the
the thing where you sort of have an
office and you work in that office eight
to five or eight ten or whatever the
heck you mount of time you work it is
much more distributed okay so you know
companies will go where people are and
they will establish their offices as
well so what is happening is more and
more software projects more and more
these projects are obviously
multidisciplinary and also
geographically separated where genius
are working with one another so we
haven't gone there yet but but the
vision is that students will get a
preview to working in that way when they
do this when they work in the Hawaiian
freh structure so imagine a world where
where you were actually running projects
in many universities for example are
teaching the same course and they are
they have these projects that near they
are working on collaboratively and they
are not just in that particular
department but they are in different
schools and they collaborate agree I
mean you know for people coming out with
that level of training coming out into
the real world is the job market that's
amazing that's very very cool that's
real world training that even for
example the industry doesn't have to do
so we're not there yet because as I as I
was talking about the same sort of thing
in an earlier event one of the
professors said to me that hey I don't
know how to great great people that way
so yeah that's true but you know I'm
sure that you know people can sort of
think about how
so with that we will have a Q&A session
maybe afterwards what I'm going to do is
hopefully now you have some sort of
sense of why we're doing it where we're
coming from why we're doing this you
know hopefully you feel the excitement
that we feel here and and you know I all
sort of want to get the message that we
are very very open to any kinds of
feedback any kinds of comments you do
because leaving Microsoft on the side
for a second and thinking it just purely
from from you know sort of an
intellectual capacity thinking about the
students the new generation all that
stuff we really want to do this right
okay so we have a lot of ideas but you
are the people who actually do this
thing you are is sort of in the trenches
so you know if you tell us if we give us
a lot of these feedback we will I
promise you that we take each one of
these in and think about it deeply and
try to incorporate them or a period of
time so with that thank you very much
for listening to me for the last five
six minutes or whatever badge and I'm
going to pass it on to Brian who's going
to actually get into some level of
detail not too much but to give you a
sense of what it is that I've just
talked about and then we had a notice to
it okay Thank You vicar so I'm going to
give more of a little bit technical meat
as to what it is we're actually I'm
going to be providing or i should say
provided in the last semester the next
semester is probably going to be run
fairly similar to the previous semester
so what I'm going to talk about is sort
of give a quick overview of what it is
that we're doing then i'm going to give
an example of the sort of application
that students might want to build just
to sort of put all the pieces together
and paint a big hole pitcher and then
i'm going to do very quickly i'm going
to give some details on what each of the
different things are that we're
providing so as Victor mentioned the
whole point of this this project is to
provide sort of the building blocks the
the low-level infrastructure that people
writing mobile cloud apps might need to
develop a nice app and there's a lot of
sort of in
get pieces involved in creating some of
these more complex apps and things can
get pretty messy really quickly and so a
big part of what we wanted to do was to
sort of take care of the basic stuff
sort of like provide an operating system
for the cloud as opposed to you know a
whole bunch of libraries that you
normally have when you write code for
for say a laptop or a desktop computer
you take advantage of all these things
that are already there for you and the
idea here is to do the same sort of
thing for cloud apps to provide a set of
sort of very basic services that provide
things that allow the students to create
much more intricate apps than they could
then if they're starting sort of from
scratch and had to write everything
themselves so when you think about these
cloud enabled mobile applications
they're really distributed systems and
all be good and bad that that entails so
you have large numbers of pieces of
things all talking to each other and so
some of the things that that we're
working on providing besides the device
itself and people might have websites or
web services that they also build
themselves and then we would also
provide various services for doing
things like authentication location
mapping just to clarify the difference
between location and mapping location
tells you where you are in terms of like
latitude longitude whereas mapping tells
you if you have this latitude longitude
this is the street address that
corresponds to that or this is an aerial
photo of the area or where you are in a
map and also a notification service
which it's actually very hard for a
phone because it's always moving all the
time and gets different IP addresses
wherever it goes to be always available
to a service that might want to send it
in notification so we provide a
notification service that allows a
another service or entity that's
connected to the cloud to send a
notification to to a client or a group
of clients so to given this sort of a
concrete example of what something like
this would look like
I'm going to show an example here I Find
My Phone app and the idea is you have
actually someone who just came by our
demo booth told me he could use this
week ago because he lost his phone but
if you lose your phone then you go back
to this website and you ask the phone to
report in and the phone will be notified
and it'll let you see where it is on a
map and so what would you need if you're
a student trying to build this well
we're providing basically all the things
with the green background to the
students and the students would build
the actual find my phone website and web
service and the little bit of code that
goes on mobile phone as well and how a
user would use this is they would go to
the website they would say they want to
register the phone they download a
little application from the website onto
their phone and then their phone would
register itself with the website and
then the phone gets lost it washes up on
a desert island somewhere and the user
goes back to the website and now they
want to i authenticate themselves so
they can prove that they're the owner of
that phone that's lost because you don't
want just anybody saying your phone is
lost and finding out where you are so
the user can authenticate themselves and
then they can issue a notification to
the the phone saying I want to know
where you're at and the phone then can
look itself up on the using the location
service to find its location send that
back to the website the website can
provide that to the user and the user
can actually get a map showing its
location in the real world using bing
maps so currently this is our platform
is Victor mentioned we plan to expand
the number of services that we we have
as time goes on but for the last
semester this is what we provided we
provided an HTC phone this guy right
here and access to windows azure for
writing your own websites and services
in the cloud and also a number of SDKs
tools and sample code for
or using windows live ID location
services being maps and the notification
service oops sorry wrong button so this
is the phone that we provided last time
it's a windows mobile 6.5 phone we're
probably going to use windows mobile 6.5
again in the fall semester simply
because windows mobile seven windows
phone 7 won't be available until near
the end of the semester so we'll
probably use Windows Phone 7 though in
the in the spring this phone is fairly
capable it's got a nice high resolution
and it has Wi-Fi and Bluetooth in
addition to 3G and it has a built-in GPS
unit a camera and a bunch of other
sensors and useful stuff we also provide
a development environment for writing
code that runs on the phone and that
uses the visual studio and the Windows
Mobile SDK we also provided the location
API this is for use in accessing the
location service and students could use
this to to write code that would find
out where their phone is similarly the
Bing Maps API once you know where your
phone is you can map it or vice versa
you can put in an address and find out
what its lat long should be of a
particular location and then Windows
Azure we were is so azure I don't know
if everyone's familiar with it it's a
Microsoft's cloud service offering it
provides the ability to basically write
your own web services or websites as
well as do database storage in the cloud
and this allows students to to basically
create their own website they don't have
to worry about registering the name
because there's it their website
automatically gets a name and sub under
the subdomain cloud app done yet and so
it's really easy for a student to create
their own website or their own web
service and provide an alternative you I
to the the mobile phones you I itself am
and then live ID is just an
authentication service which
one allows somebody to prove that
they're the same person that was at a
website before and this just saves the
students from having to write all this
kind of stuff themselves I mean this is
it's pretty straightforward but it's the
kind of thing that if someone's done it
already for you it it's not the
interesting stuff that we want the
students to concentrate on and finally
we wrote our own notification service
again mobile devices they don't have
fixed IP addresses so they're hard to
talk to if they're out roaming around
the notification service automatically
keeps track of them so that if you need
to send a notification from somewhere to
one of these mobile devices it can make
sure it gets routed correctly so that
the mobile device can get the
notification and since there are
basically as you might have noticed I
went through kind of quickly but there's
a lot of SDKs and development
environments and you know visual studio
and things like this that students might
otherwise need to download and install
and configure and put together and one
of the feedback we got in the previous
semester was that this took a lot of
time and a lot of effort so to make it
easier for for the students we're going
to provide a virtual machine that has
all these things already downloaded
installed and configured on it so that a
student can just quickly load up the BM
and launch right into to coding their
app and not have to worry about all this
configuration stuff and for you know
inevitably people have questions either
students want to talk amongst themselves
about it people seeing the same sort of
things they're seeing when they try to
this that or the other thing or they
want to ask us a question about how to
do something so we also provide a forum
on Microsoft reshoots community website
which allows the students to just
interact with geeth other or or us and
once they have their app they can give
us a pointer to it and we'll list it on
our
our appt depot which runs on both on the
phone and there's a website and this
allows the students to see what other
students are writing and download and
try to try out their their applications
so when the student you know finishes
writing an application or even in the
middle of writing application wants
people to try outs or their beta they
can release it here and all the other
students in the courses can access and
try it out this so if you're interested
in this project we have this website on
Microsoft Research is main website
research that microsoft com / hawaii
will get you to our project website and
then we have a for the for the students
or people who are participating we have
a website that has more certain in it
agree details about how to how to code
to things and you know where to get all
the different pieces you need and has
some other pointers and tips and stuff
like that and one of the things that
we've been aiming to provide is this
project is lots of example code so
there's no there's a huge slew of
services that we're providing and
sometimes that it's hard to know how to
use them and and most of them come of
some examples but it never hurts to have
a few more and the other thing that we
wanted to do though is that most things
that come with example code they rarely
show example code that also includes how
to use it with something else so one of
the big things we tried to do with our
example code was to combine things using
different services together to show how
you would you would interface the pieces
with one another which is something that
often isn't covered by example ok and
that's my talk if I can take questions
now if anybody hasn't yes oh I'm sorry
he's going to bring you a mic
the the service like find my phone does
it work with the same number or does it
work with the embedded number in the
handset so for example if I think
somebody steals my phone and obviously
the first thing they'll do is change the
same it doesn't use the same is the
number which comes at the manufacturing
time yeah yes there's a there's an
embedded device ID inside windows mobile
phones and there's an API that allows
you to retrieve actually a hashed
version of it for privacy reasons you
have to provide a hash string that's
unique to your app but you're the result
is that your app gets a unique ID for
every phone and it's hard coded into the
fee even if same as change you still
contribute the same as chance you'd
still use your phone yes Brad actually
this is a little bit random but I just
happened to come upon the Star Trek
stuff that Sean do that God's group did
msre Silicon Valley about computing /
tracks of mobility and stuff like this
is a moba cyst paper like a couple years
ago or so is that by any chance
available as part of this is it what's
its relationship to Azure and Hawaii is
there any relationship or I'm just
random question perhaps too random sorry
that one I think the answer is might it
be part of so the short I'm sorry is
pick this up because of a recording the
short answer is that it's not part of
the Hawaii service now but you know
think of sort of that is this this is
actually what the intention of Hawaii is
which is there are lots of research
projects out there and as they mature
they didn't get pulled into Hawaii
infrastructure and they have to be at a
point where they actually quite really
usable by everybody else so so that's a
separate project done it's kind of cool
and now that you mentioned it I don't
think hard about seeing it whether we
can pull it in
any other questions yes but what's
what's the IP restrictions and is there
are privacy issues with students using
the azure system I don't I believe that
the students using the azure are just
restricted to whatever the standard
terms of use are fresher we don't have
any special terms of use outside of the
regular terms of use Fraser in terms of
using using our code there is the only
thing is that we ask that people using
the location system ask the user before
they start finding out their location so
that nobody you know is being tracked
and you know against their wishes or
anything like that so we do ask that
anybody calling the location API make
sure the user knows they're doing that
before they do it but other than that we
don't have any terrible privacy concerns
i don't think that are associated with
the project as well as is if you know
our members of the team willing to come
out give you know short guest lectures
or attack these are mechanisms for
technical support so so too so the first
part of that question we actually that's
been a commonly requested thing as as a
basically the end of the first semester
we we got some feedback that people
would like to see that we don't
currently have any formulated course
where we're thinking about including
that or allowing people to contribute
that for a redistribution in terms of
our previous semester I actually went
personally visited all the schools
involved and gave a short tutorial
lecture and talk to any of the
interested students planning to do that
again next semester of there are too
many schools it might be a little hard
to schedule them all but we'll see yes
do you have any partnership with Kerry
so that the phones are activated they
have a phone plan they can really use
the phone that we do not have so we
provided for the last semester we
provided the phones but no data plans so
the schools either use the Wi-Fi so that
they could get did access on the phones
using the Wi-Fi which works just fine as
long as you have Wi-Fi beverage wherever
you want to use it or the students just
use their own sim cards in the phones
any others or I think we'll go to Stuart
you're going to demo boy oh I was just
showing that yeah this is what our
application exchange looks like where
you can select one of these these
examples and then choose to download it
install it on your friends so anyways
let's go back to okay thank you how
about thanks ok hello a podium I'm
Stuart tansley here this is a bit of an
interesting context for me in this
project I've been involved with their
networking for almost half of my career
but you may know me more as one of the
devices people in external research in
Microsoft Research where I've been doing
robotics and sensor networks for a
number of years but I have been loved to
work with the victors team and Ed Brian
who I worked with closely when I first
came to Microsoft back in 2001 and we
did ipv6 together and I've been managing
to do a number of networking activities
over the year over the years including
the software radio program that's in the
in the demo fest booth as well as the
Hawaii project going forward though
Judith precip has joined us today and
please see a director for computer
science because this is also a computer
science education program as well as
networking research going forward I will
transition to Judith and her team
but you always get a good answer for me
if you have any questions later I want
to do perhaps a little bit of an
extended Jerry Springer thing a comment
was made yesterday about final thoughts
on the presentations that you've just
heard from Victor and Brian at we
external research or the group that
supports our researchers in reaching you
folks they can talk to you directly but
they're inevitably bandwidth-limited
they can only talk to a few few of you a
few dozen of you maybe but we can
hopefully magnify what they can do with
our resources and our program management
and we are wanting to work together with
the victors team and these are some
thoughts that we presented a month ago
and we launched this at moby sis 2010 so
available today for pioneers that want
to go for this right now we're not
holding you back we encourage you if you
want to go through the regular download
the software from msdnaa approach we we
can't give you phones on demand hardware
it gets a little pricey so we can't just
give you phones of you if you want them
on demand but if you have phones already
we have all the documentation available
at this website and while we don't
author the courseware well we've had
this feedback that perhaps some course
where would be good we tend to be a bit
reluctant about writing course we're
four professors we're not the best
authors of a lecture material we do
PowerPoint decks maybe you do PowerPoint
that's too but we we really want to
empower you folks with the information
the technical information you can
populate your own slides and own course
where we're also just going to give you
this the Microsoft only materials you
probably want to enhance that with a
broader explanation well as brian has
already said but just in summary we're
targeting the fall semester for our
version 1 point 0 what we did in the
spring semester this year would consider
it a pilot at duke USC and university of
wisconsin-madison those guys were very
happy guinea pigs as as victor as
explained we've got some really good
feedback from them but we're also
planning for the long term here there's
not a one shot deal and we're already
thinking about the spring and hopefully
that's the best time
for windows phone 7 we we keep on
pressuring Brian who's the main
developer on this project to get Windows
Phone 7 ready but yeah maybe maybe
january is the best time for that the
package in summary is the software and
the services but right now download it
all separately from msdnaa many of you
will know that that can get a bit scary
especially with an embedded platform
like the windows mobile phone here
there's a lot of bits and pieces that
that you have to do so brian is done
sterling work in packaging this up as a
single VM the single virtual machine
download much simpler install experience
we really hoping to to see that model
for our deployment extend to many of the
not only research but also education
programs from microsoft it is coming
we're one of the early ones on that
there are in structure materials already
from this website that are produced by
the the pilot courses it's early day so
you know some of it is not not a tidy
right now that you'll have to do some
construction but we hope to package that
up for the the fall a little bit more
tidier for you so many student materials
there's an app store this is not the the
commercial retail microsoft app store
for windows mobile phone and windows
phone 7 going forward this is our own a
student world and research word for
students to produce their apps they can
share amongst each other with the with
their their peers and with their
professors and we also want to be see
this as a part of a community of people
talking about how what this idea is as
Victor's explained well of the mobile
and cloud as a default platform for
writing applications let's not assume
that let's not think about our
platformers as anything but the mobile
and cloud is there as a given now what
cool applications can I build on that
what cool service is going to provide on
that what extensions can I build as a
student some remarks needs these
comments so anyone can download this is
freely available there
restrictions over this we've not had put
a heavy burden of some sort of IP or
licenses it's the regular academic use
of software from microsoft so typically
if you're familiar with msdnaa it's that
kind of thing phone hardware will be
available selectively we do have budget
for home phone hardware I do try and
manage expectations on that this is not
a major marketing push from right
offices X this is external research in
Microsoft Research we we have some
limited budget for for phones but there
will be phones available we have an
approach to the technical materials the
documentation is modular so I know
there's been asked for instructure
material or lecture material from us but
we want to provide materials that you
can use pick and mix materials in a
modular way so it's not a complete
course it's not a complete training set
in fact it's not even training materials
this is technical documentation and the
professor or third materials that you
can use in your lecture notes there's a
combination here of Microsoft products
and Mike's off research technology and
the services are from various places but
usually for Microsoft and so there's
this package we're trying to put a good
envelope on that for you but it is a
combination of things and it's not a
it's not like a full-blown product a
single product from Microsoft so you
will need to get involved in the
community and look for peer support but
as well as the active partition from
Victor's team I think something I would
like to highlight that Victor's perhaps
didn't stress so much today but really
engagement with the research team is one
of the benefits of what we're offering
today that is that is a rare thing this
is because it's not a marketing program
this is a engagement with the research
team lastly what we plan to do subject
to change because we're looking for your
feedback we would we it's not locked in
stone we are rough and running here
we've got a program but we're open to
feedback we're going to survey the pilot
courses for lessons learned we have
budget for about 250
phone sir and the sims maybe well let's
get some feedback on what what the
implications are I would love there to
be a partnership with a service provider
there isn't one right now but if you
have any any good contacts in letters
name we're going to produce the download
packages the vm package I we do have a
full intention to to migrate to our new
platform windows phone 7 we're on the
brink of having that available
internally with a developer phone so
we're eagerly waiting for that we've got
access already to the software kits but
we we know people want the hardware so
it's pointless doing a program which is
software only right now but the hardware
is tantalizingly close we plan to set up
a student competition arm I'm keen and
it's been suggested to us and feedback
internally that we integrate with
imagine cup imagine cup just finished
its finals for this year in Poland in
Warsaw can we actuators to the Thai team
apparently I did a phenomenal job
imagine cup is and the major probably
the biggest I think student develop a
competition in the world 300,000
students sign up for this in 2009 I
don't even have the number for 4 2010
but having this is a special component
within imagine cup I think would make a
lot of sense so look for that coming and
we're seeking feedback from interested
professors yourselves you are here do
check out the website I think Brian just
put up links right the screenshots very
pretty we got a great beautiful website
it's very usable give us feedback on a
website if nothing if you can't find
what you need we are really open to that
right now and how to sign up my mail to
hi forum at microsoft com really s just
go straight to brian's inbox but we we
check all the mail and let us know what
you think give us feedback on what
you've heard and if you're interested in
engaging with us on this then please let
us know that's it for now any final
questions before we wrap up for the next
session thank you
ok
okay thanks so let me we've been
speaking for about 40 minutes 50 minutes
now you know you heard what we said let
me ask like a sort of simple question
how many of you actually let's say how
many of you have been thinking about
teaching a course on mobility and in
cloud okay that's quite a few that's
great to know because I certainly
believe that you know sort of the future
that's where the future is and that's
where the world is changing I would like
to get some some thoughts from you guys
anybody can contribute about how you
were thinking about doing this and what
were you going to do anybody want to
take a shot yeah
so we're sort of developing a
three-course sequence the first course
will be developing mobile applications
that will probably include you know
hopefully include components of the
cloud as well for for engineers who are
non computer science majors so it's a
you know so we're looking at your
competitors new product for you know
doing drag and drop interfaces and
things like you know the App Inventor
right the second two courses are for
computer science students one will be a
pure mobile computing cloud computing
application development course we have a
collection of pure technology courses
like that and this will be one of them
and then the third one is what we're
calling distributed enterprise
technology so this will be a module one
week module within that overall course
and in a sense culminating these will
these courses will lead into our
capstone programs so there will be a
project which we're actually working
with Microsoft to incorporate the
imagine cup into the capstone courses so
there'll be a sort of a project-based a
capstone where these technologies will
be used to develop some kind of
application any other thoughts
ok my name is sin Lewin from UC Davis
computer science department actually
taught a class on computer networks and
as an experiment i use androids cause
project Pat the end of the class this is
what I learned good a bad hop on
students love it and half student hate
it because they're a indeed is a
learning curve and another part I think
this will be really helpful is when we
were doing the project basically student
have to learn everything and there's no
component for them to use per se but I
think some for example if you really
want to develop a large larger
application some components as I dr.
Brennan late earlier today well I think
will be really helpful have locations
and some kind of servers in the cloud to
help with that I think will be really
helpful just as another experience or
another colleague of mine at the UC
Davis actually taught her mobile phone
application development class as a two
course project I mean to quote a project
course as kind of capstone type of stuff
and that was really successful a lot of
student teamed up and did iphone app
development and enjoyed development I
think again for in that context what I
learned is well if there's some
infrastructure support like what you
have here will be very helpful thank you
thanks Brad Carper Musial so Kyle
Jamison and I have already signed up to
in Spring of 2011 teach a mobile cloud
focused class so since we've already
signed up I figured I should at least
say a couple things of what we were
thinking we would do we're going to be
teaching I guess you could sort of call
it a traditional graduate seminar in the
sense that it's going to be research
paper focused so cloud mobile cloud
computing isn't exactly an established
research area of its own just yet maybe
that would be the result of the teaching
of classes like this over a few years so
it's probably going to have several
distinct
threads and actually stole this idea
shamelessly from Ramesh's course I'd
encourage everyone that was the one that
I spent the most time looking at but
Ramesh's graduate seminar had threads of
papers drawn from distributed systems
from cloud computing from security and
privacy sort of areas that are perhaps
somewhat more established in computer
systems and networking research trying
to sort of find a way to through
discussion integrate them into a hole
for mobile cloud computing and to sort
of provide background for students to
really do not just two apps but sort of
apps with an angle of research on them
for graduate students and so I think
that's really the focus of what we're
doing one thing that might be somewhat
unique about the way we do things at UCL
is that students do a master's thesis in
the graduate program and so probably we
will have some number of students do
group master's thesis projects where
they can sort of have several months
when they're not taking classes because
the master's degree at UCL includes
several months in the summer when
there's no class activity nothing but
thesis and so students will have a
several month period where they can work
together as a group and hopefully build
something pretty substantial and so
that's something that we're looking
forward to Thanks right
my mark Chang from Olin College and for
the past two years we've been teaching
I've been teaching a mobile apps course
and I think the thing that two things
that I found is one is at its you can be
completely independent of other CS
courses it can be fully integrated
because it's really a fantastic
motivating tool for students to learn
concepts like Java if you're using
Android c-sharp using other platforms
but the way that we've run the course is
as kind of a synthesis course between
kind of interaction design and human
factors design entrepreneurship as well
as engineering because I think with the
kind of ecosystems that we have now with
at least a android in the iphone having
kind of the direct channel to actual
consumers students really can get the
whole experience from product concept
all the way through delivery to end user
which makes them do things like actual
testing regression testing multiple
device testing and those kinds of things
and having eyeballs in the millions of
end users on their applications actually
is a very strong motivator to do actual
real coding instead of kind of class
project coding okay I've been asked to
wrap up so I will I want to make one
distinction between you know I guess you
know iphone & G phones or whatever they
are very popular I know I we sort of
understand that aspect but if you think
about Apple as an example Apple is a non
player when it comes to cloud services
it doesn't necessarily have you know
they've done a pretty good job with sort
of these end devices but they have not
necessarily done a great enough job in
in the cloud so one of the value
proposition that Hawaii has I mean even
though what you've seen is it's just a
kickoff so you have some basic services
that you have seen that we that we
thought are absolutely necessary to
provide to start it off but is that I
want to highlight is ms ours back end
and what I mean by that is there are a
tremendous amount of the technologies
deep-rooted technology since its speaker
recognition or natural language
processing or machine learning or
pattern recognition and things like that
which can be brought to bear when you
start to write these really really
interesting services for the phones okay
so
so if you want to sort of be at the cusp
off not only teaching the students you
know in this new world that I keep
talking about and all but also take them
to the edge where they're actually
looking at some of these hardcore
technologies and realizing the fact that
you need to offload the fact that you
are going to be resource addicted and
don't get too enamored by by just
solutely sophisticated now if you know
your nap with data for that then you
start to see what the value proposition
here is but anyway that that's what sort
of my final comment i hope you you've
got the gist of it we are all available
you know as I said to begin with a very
passionate very excited very energized
about this thing and we're going to keep
pushing it and we'll keep learning and
as we learn we can keep incorporating
new ideas new thoughts and we we would
flourish if if we get partners
partnerships from you and and this is
sort of becomes a very collaborative
effort in the future so thank you very
much for being here I appreciate your
being here